could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
no one ever teaches us how to deal with
negative emotions that's the big problem
i think i've watched daniel pink's
videos as a way to inspire me
for years the world is littered with
people who have a decent amount of
innate talent who didn't put in the work
here's the thing about us human beings
we stink at solving our own problems we
fear that when we share our stakes our
vulnerabilities our regrets people will
think less of us the fact that those
regrets stuck with me for 10 years
that's telling me something
real courage is staring your regrets in
the eye and doing something about them
we are on this planet for a vanishingly
small amount of time and you're not
using that time wisely the best way to
improve
is to
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
daniel yes you've um
you've lived a really remarkable life
and obviously the the most remarkable
thing
that from my perspective that i've seen
from your i don't know the last 20 years
of your life is you became a person
who's really remarkably good at
communicating and understanding um
complex ideas and then conveying them in
a way which is really engaging
is there anything and i was i was
looking through your childhood as much
as i possibly could it sounds creepy
right is there anything from your early
years that when you look back set you up
to become the man you are today are
there any moments or experiences or
traumas dare i say yeah
well i mean thanks for that thanks for
that nice compliment um i'm probably the
worst person in the world to
psychoanalyze me but um
i would say if there's anything is and
it just shows you in some ways the
circumstances of birth
i happened to live in a part of the
united states
that had one of the best public library
systems in america
i lived walking distance to an excellent
public library and i lived a bus ride
away from a giant
downtown cavernous cathedral-like
library and so i spent an enormous
amount of time as a kid
in libraries i always loved reading i
always loved words i always loved books
and my hunch and it's just a hunch
steven is that
had the circumstances of my birth been
different had i been born in another
city or another country you know maybe i
would be just a really excellent dentist
but at some point you became this
al gore speech writer
and i look at when i look at people's
skill stacks you can sometimes point at
the thing
you're really looking for the quite
unique but complementary skill right and
for me it's all well and good knowing a
bunch of stuff being it but being able
to communicate
that intelligence in a way that's
engaging and compelling is a very unique
part of your skill stack which is
probably the reason why your books do so
well your ted talk was a smash hit
and everything in between where did that
skill come from
you know i i i don't know i think a lot
of it comes
but i think it comes from perhaps from
two things okay one of them is something
that i feel like a lot of other people
don't do which is
think about things from another person's
perspective what do they understand what
do they know what are their reference
points i think that's extraordinarily
important it's something that i learned
how to do probably a little bit later in
life the other thing i mean
is work
for instance i give you so so for my
books for instance i will do multiple
multiple drafts of every chapter i will
read aloud every chapter to my wife
often multiple times
what's even worse my wife will read
chapters aloud to me so i can hear it to
try to essentially make every word that
i write fight for its life that is that
word has to look at me and say i deserve
to live before i
knock it out and so i think that that
simplicity and conciseness that come
just from effort are really the key
and that's
so evident especially in the book that i
just read which is the power of regret
your new book and even harry who read it
as well in my team when he walked into
my office about an hour ago he goes he's
very very succinct with his points
i think harry said there's like no fluff
thank you harry yeah that's my goal
truly and why is that important because
i hate reading fluff myself
i mean you know truly stephen i want to
write books that the kinds of books that
i want to read and what i what i don't
like is when i read a book and it is
let's say 60 000 words long and there's
4 000 words of ideas in here it's like
hey why don't you just write me a 4 000
word article there's so many nonfiction
books i think that would be twice as
good if they were half as long and so i
try to make it as lean as possible and
make it as fluff free as i possibly can
and okay let's start then with the some
of the things that you've written going
back to 2001 sure free agent nation why
did you write that book
well you know i think you might if you
want to see a theme emerging here you'll
see the theme that all researchers me
search and so how did i how did i how
did i become a how did i write free
agent nation i i went and started
working for myself this is like 1998-99
and i noticed that a lot of people were
doing it was the first stirrings of that
i thought it was something big going on
and i decided to write about it by
traveling around just the u.s and
interviewing people who had gone out on
their own saying i think this is going
to be a bit this is an emerging big deal
and that a lot of people are going to
work this way and we better understand
what it means how it happened what the
implications are one of the key themes
in that book that i i found particularly
i mold over that's the thing that i
stopped on and i was thinking a little
bit about is this idea that persistence
trumps talent
what do you mean by that
here's the thing the world is littered
with people who have a decent amount of
innate talent who didn't put in the work
and the people who really flourish are
the people who
show up
and they show up the next day and they
show up the next day and they do their
work and they don't get freaked out by
setbacks and they show up the next day
and the next day and the next day
they're consistent they are they are
tenacious and they just worry about each
day doing the work and to me that is
how
the best creators are
the best business people are
the best contributors of any kind are if
i had if i sat around and waited to be
inspired to write
i don't i wouldn't write a syllable you
know i show up to write because that's
my freaking job and that's how you
create stuff you show up and you and you
work and you show up and you work and so
when i was starting out in writing i
looked around and i noticed that there i
felt like there were people who were
more innately talented than i was
definitely but
i had to decide
no one's going to outwork me
it's so funny because i obviously agree
i'm going to play devil's advocate here
but yeah because the thing that i always
try and get to the heart of when i talk
about consistency and persistence and i
i've seen your examples about
compounding returns yeah as it relates
to finance etc is
why aren't some people persistent i know
there's many many factors yeah is it
self-belief is it is it not being
intrinsically motivated by the task
itself and doing it for the wrong
reasons is it a combination of all these
factors i think that it's a combination
of all of those factors i think it's i
think it starts at a pretty high level i
think part of it is that is that people
don't know they actually believe the
opposite that talent is more important
than persistence and so they believe
they're talented and they think that
great things will happen to them simply
because of their status as a talented
person so they're wrong at like a meta
level right the other thing is that um
i do think that part of it is a miss of
of intrinsic motivation uh but it's it's
different um it's intrinsic motivation
not because every day is joyful uh but
because every day is
necessary
and every day is at least somewhat
meaningful
you know and so there's an adage
that being a professional is showing up
um to do something you love even on the
days you don't feel like doing it and
and that to me that to me is is is the
key like like i like writing
some days but not every day some days
it's a gigantic pain in the ass some
days it's really really hard but i have
to show up and do the work that day too
and that's what being a professional is
it's showing up and doing the work even
on the days where you know what i'm not
that into it today in the
self-development community
i think that there's been this growing
feeling that you can like wake up in the
morning say some nice things in the
mirror i'm gonna be a millionaire i'm
amazing
and then life will somehow bring about
all of these wonderful things that
you've manifested
and honestly when i when i hear people
talking about manifestation
i feel quite in the in the in the
cultural context they're almost like
spiritual cultural context and personal
development they do
i
it's almost comical
and i i am
i feel sorry for them and their chances
of achieving any of those things what's
your view on manifestation in the like
i'm not talking about
setting yourself a goal and then going
after it i'm just like just kind of like
fluffy say it to yourself write it in
your notebook and then it will happen
type stuff i don't know and have you
seen that am i just
i mean you know
they're yeah i'm i'm skeptical i'm
skeptical now we there is some now
there's some interesting stuff there's
some interesting
research on this question that we can go
to because i always like things that are
evidence-based and i haven't seen a lot
of evidence that manifestation is a is a
winning technique my view is like if it
works for you you like it god bless you
go for it do it just but you're still
going to need to show up to work
um but there's some other very
interesting research um uh in what's
called uh in certain kinds of self-talk
okay so what you're talking about in in
some ways is self-talk so how do we talk
to how do we talk to ourselves and
there's some interesting research
showing that if you say to yourself
before a big encounter
you can do it you got this okay so let's
say i'm going to pitch a new book i can
say to myself you got this you're going
to crush it no that that's actually
better than not doing anything okay that
kind of self-talk but it's not the best
thing you can do the best thing we you
can do is something known as
interrogative self-talk interrogative
self-talk where you turn it into a
question
now the manifestation people hate that
all right but instead what you say is
can you do this
and if so how can you do this and if so
how you ask a question rather than make
that bold assertion
and now here's the interesting thing
questions by their very nature elicit an
active response or you know i ask a
question you ask me a question my my my
wheels have to turn but we ask ourselves
a question the wheels also turn so if i
say to myself let's say i'm pitching a
new book can you do this well
yeah i can do this because i've pitched
books before but this time i have to
think about it because harry over there
there's never liked an idea that i want
so i got to make sure that i
really focus on harry
last time i talked too much and listened
to poorly so i gotta chill out a little
bit what am i doing i'm rehearsing i'm
preparing i'm practicing and that's
actually more muscular than the
nominally muscular thing of you can do
it you got this which is not terrible so
um so that's my view on that's my
general view on on manifest on
manifestation manifestation without work
is a is delusion
yeah okay but um manifestation with work
isn't the worst thing in the world and
self-talk rooted in evidence especially
interrogative self-talk can be really
smart
drive that was the the gateway piece of
content that um put me onto your work
specifically the ted talk me and my
girlfriend watched it
uh together and we weren't planning on
watching it i think i clicked on it and
then it was so engaging and delivery
that it held us for the entire i think
it was about 20 minutes yeah wow and
it's done some 10 million views and then
there's been you know i saw the
illustrated version of it which i think
is done 18 million views it's crazy the
numbers on that
um the base premise of that is obviously
kind of debunking this thesis we had
about how to motivate people and keep
them engaged in work
and you you are certain you prove that
autonomy mastery and purpose are a much
more compelling formula sure that
journey of writing that book
and um going on yeah the journey of
doing the research how did it change
your view on
how to keep employees engaged and if you
i don't know if you if you build
companies now but on how to treat people
because i came away from it thinking i
understand
but what are the things i can do now as
a employer to to make sure that the team
you see around me today are motivated
sure yeah sure so so what it so again i
can summarize i can i can summarize the
that book it looks at about 50 years of
science in what really motivates people
but i can summarize the main point very
very simply which is this there's a
certain kind of motivator we use in
organizations psychologists call it a
controlling contingent motivator
again let's go back to simplicity that's
a lot of syllables let's just call it an
if then reward right makes a lot more
sense if you do this then you get that
if you do this then you get that
60 years of science now tells us that if
then rewards are actually pretty good
for tasks that are simple to do and that
have a short time horizon
human beings love rewards you dangle a
reward in front of in front of anybody
myself included you've got their
attention been in that very narrow way
but if then rewards the science tells us
are less great for more complex tasks
with longer time horizons tasks that
require judgment creativity discernment
conceptual thinking and the reason is
the same if then rewards narrow our
focus for a lot of tasks particularly
the tasks that most people are doing
most creators are doing most people in
the creative economy are doing you want
to have a more expansive focus and so
so we got to get rid of that way of
motivating people for the bulk of things
that people are doing today and what the
research tells us is you got to pay
people fairly and pay people well
you got to pay people fairly and pay
people well and then you want to offer
as exactly as you say some autonomy some
some control some sovereignty over what
you do how you do it when you do it
where you do it
mastery which is a chance to get better
at something that matters to make
progress and meaningful work and a sense
of purpose
do you know why you're doing it are you
making a contribution are you making a
are you making a difference so we can
talk in a more granular level about what
specifically to do
did you ever figure out from your
research why autonomy mastery and
purpose
why they are the things that motivate us
and keep us most engaged in work why why
those things it's a great question and
and it's a question that
i think is embedded in that work that
most people don't see embedded in there
because that's who we are as human
beings we are innately
autonomous i'll give you give you an
example the best example go find me a
two-year-old anywhere on the planet
she's going to be self-directed she's
going to be resisting control
she's going to be
engaged and interested and curious about
stuff that's autonomy she is going to
want to get better at something she's
going to want to learn and grow that's
who she is right
two-year-old
why why is this why am i doing this why
am i doing this for you it's the same
thing that's who we are that's why these
things are so important they're part of
what it means to be human and so that's
why they're so powerful and i think
what's interesting stephen is that for a
long time in organizations of any kind
but certainly the the business most
businesses today certainly the business
that you've built what you have
for a long time we've had to
run organizations that went against the
grain of human nature because that was
efficient that efficiency was the
highest thing and the only way to
achieve efficiency was actually through
some mechanisms of control by saying ah
it doesn't matter why we're doing this
just freaking do it all right so control
and and um and those kind of those are
very very tight measurements those tight
uh mechanisms
now i think
the best businesses the best
organizations
go with the grain of human nature that's
the key that's why these things are so
powerful because it's part of who we are
and organizations that build contacts
that go with the grain of human nature
are going to be better they're going to
be better places to work because people
aren't going to be miserable but they're
also going to be more effective
i guess so i get the autonomy point
right i understood mastery what does
that mean it means that people have an
innate desire to get better at stuff to
learn and to grow i'll give you an
example think about
i mean the most mundane example any
weekend anywhere here in london in
washington d.c where i live what are you
gonna have you're gonna have people who
are
playing musical instruments on the
weekend why
are they making any money off of it no
are they planning for a career as
professional musicians no why are they
doing it
because they like it and it's fun to get
better at qatar it's fun to get better
at violin in my neighborhood in
washington dc there is a big soccer
field a big soccer pitch about two
blocks away why on weekends are those
things swarmed with guys my age running
around in shorts are they going to be
playing professional soccer no are they
going to get famous as soccer players no
why do they like it because it's
interesting because it's fun because i
like getting better at it that's why
that is an innate part of what it is to
be human human beings innately want to
learn and grow now here's the thing
i think that's our nature this is
important
i think that certain
institutions can change the default
setting on that nature i think that when
we ship all right let's think about
human beings as products all right the
default setting of human beings is
autonomy master and purpose i am
convinced of that
i think that sometimes in school
or other kinds of experiences that
default gets flipped and people learn
compliance they stop caring about
mastery they care they don't care as
much about why but i think that is
because
the context that they're in has thwarted
their natural their natural state and
what's the consequences of when that
dial is turned and they become compliant
and because that must be them going
against their human innate
wiring so there must be a consequence of
that right i think the consequence is
dull misery in some cases i think the
consequence is
under performance and i think that there
is a
significant
meta-consequence that people aren't
reckoning with which is that
we are on this planet
for a vanishingly small amount of time
and you're not using that time wisely
and at a certain point in your life
you're going to say oh my god i totally
messed up
and you know one of the things you see
let's take autonomy for example the
thing about these words stephen is that
they're they're they're abstract so so a
way that i try to think about abstract
questions sometimes
is
to think about what's the opposite of a
concept so let's take the opposite of
autonomy help us understand the opposite
of autonomy is control
human beings have only two reactions to
control
they comply
or they defy that's it i mean in some
ways the history of human civilization
is that
human beings trying to control other
human beings they comply until they
can't take it anymore and they defy but
if you're building an organization do
you want people who are perfectly
compliant you want some compliance and
certain things but you don't want people
who are 100 compliant all the time
they're not going to do great work you
want people who are defined no you want
people who are engaged and the way that
human beings engage is by getting there
under their own steam the way that human
beings engage is through self-direction
and then the last point about purpose
yeah
when people think about purpose
especially i think younger generations
they always think about trying to save
the world or doing something which is
going to help others it's a really weird
thing that's happened to these this to
my generation where we all want to like
we all i don't know whether we want to
save the world or whether we want to be
seen as someone that wants to save the
world it's i'm not sure if it's virtue
signaling or if it's an innate desire
i'm not either i think that there is a
lot of virtue signaling there and let me
social media let me tell you yes let me
tell you about
let me tell you about purpose though
because and forgive me i might owe you
some money because i didn't get it quite
right on that book drive what i've
discovered since is that purpose is not
one thing it's two things and it goes
exactly to the question that you're
asking so one kind of purpose is
what i like to think of as capital p
purpose large p purpose and that is what
you're talking about i'm feeding the
hungary i am
solving the climate crisis whatever and
there's no doubt in the in the research
that that's that can be a very powerful
motivator that people who are animated
by that sen that kind of purpose
do good work that's that's very very
clear but
day to day
it's hard to get that every single day
it's hard to get that kind of purpose on
wednesday and thursday and friday and
then show up again the next it's hard to
get that every single day now it's still
important and but this is what i missed
there's a second kind of purpose that i
call small p purpose and that's just
making a contribution right capital p
purpose is making a difference small p
purpose is making a contribution did you
help a teammate get the product out the
door
did you help this customer resolve its
problem
there's a great piece of research i love
this out of harvard business school
where they had a cafeteria in boston
and in the cafeteria you know the
customers went through the line in the
cafeteria putting food on their trays
and being served food but the people
cooking the food were in the back you
couldn't see them the cooks couldn't see
the customers and the customers couldn't
see the cooks so these researchers
rigged up an ipad just like the one you
have in front of you that allowed the
cooks to see the customers and
what they were measuring and this is
forgive me for getting in the weeds here
this research but what they were
measuring the dependent variable
was not whether the cooks were satisfied
with their jobs when they saw the
customers
they were measuring the customer
evaluation of the food and so the
question they were asking is when the
cooks can see the customers does the
quality of the food change customer
ratings of the food change and the
answer was yes
customer satisfaction went up 10 percent
when the cooks could see the customers
even though the customers couldn't see
the cooks really yeah so that's what i'm
talking about here so those cooks back
there
they're they're not feeding the the the
hungry i mean people are hungry because
it's lunchtime in boston but they're not
feeding people who are destitute what's
going on here that cook
looks at somebody moving through the
line and says well wait a second another
human being is going to eat my cheese
omelet so
wow
i i know why i'm doing what i'm doing
it's not changing the world but it's
affecting one person's life so
i'm going to up my cheese omelette game
10
and and i think that that small p
purpose
is
extraordinarily important and so again
purpose is not one thing it's two things
and for organizations listening or for
anyone in a team i guess that the key
takeaway i had then is how can i make my
teams more connected to the impact
they're having with the work they're
doing because if i do that then their
work will improve and they'll find more
meaning and purpose in their work and
they'll yeah
can i can i give you a couple of ideas
so one so so one thing is that is i
think woefully underused our
testimonials and things we we often we
use companies use testimonials from
customers in an outward-facing way for
marketing they should use them as an
inward facing way to motivate employees
so if i see if i'm working for a um
let's say i'm working for a software
company and i am
working on a team of of of coders and i
never i very rarely see customers i'm
just working on my part of the code and
as part of this team but i start seeing
letters from someone who said oh my gosh
this this software transformed my life
it made me run my business a lot better
oh my gosh this software was so
incredible it allowed me to it the
efficiency was so great it allowed me to
hire three new people
showing the
individuals those letters it reminds
them of the impact of what they're doing
so that's one very powerful thing to do
the second thing as a leadership
technique and something i've been doing
i don't have the kind of operation that
you do but i work with often like
networks of people on projects and
things like that is
this is again
going back to the simplicity i like
interventions that are quick
and cheap and actionable okay not well
go take my
eight-week course on autonomous
leadership you know that's i don't
or on purpose-driven leadership you know
here's here's a here's a simple
technique which i've been doing for
probably eight or nine years
each week try to have not try do have
each week have
two fewer conversations about how
and two more about why when we're
leading people we tend to over index on
how conversations and we don't realize
it so we say okay all right here's how
you make that sales presentation okay
okay here's how you deal with that
customer and just twice
flip it just change it stop yourself i
mean i literally stopped yourself so
when you say here's how
stop yourself and say here's why we're
making that sales presentation here's
why we're dealing with that that vendor
just twice a week and what you'll see
it becomes habitual it becomes habitual
you have more
you have more why conversations how
conversations are still important
but you sprinkle in a few more y
conversations and you almost always see
an uptick in performance
that's really really fascinating um
berta and my team who's actually sat
over there um one of the things she
suggested doing
was
we added a
section to our company chat just called
impact and we we did that so
in the impact chat it just shows
feedback from people that listen to this
podcast perfect and all that enjoy our
content or whatever else and it's a
really you're right it's a really nice
feedback loop because it's very easy to
slip into the the belief that this is
actually just a bunch of numbers we see
on the screen a million people listen
this week or two million people and
that's good that's useful yeah but it
doesn't it doesn't hit like hearing
jenny who was going through a divorce
and was really suffering with her mental
health and then she listened to a
certain episode which actually sometimes
it's interesting because it might be a
certain episode that might not have had
as many listeners another one and to
hear that that episode just impacted one
person in such a profound way really
does provide a huge sense of meaning to
the whole kind of digital you never get
to see who we're impacting you know
we're the we're the chefs in the kitchen
that never get to see the food being
consumed right exactly exactly
that's it yeah it's such a small thing
but i think it's had such a significant
impact and the thing is we it's
interesting we do it already you see you
know you the sales people in any kind of
company are toting around these customer
testimonials in an outward-facing way so
yeah shine a few of them shine a few of
them inside and again these are these
are
we don't have to we don't have to reform
and change everything we don't have to
pull up the roots entirely we know how
to do these things and by starting small
and establishing them as habits and and
and regular practices they are
transformative
quick one as the seasons have begun to
change so has my diet and um
right now i'm going to be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 of the
time so i track it with 10 of my friends
in a whatsapp group and this tracker
online that we all use together we call
it fitness blockchain and i'm currently
at 81 percent
um so 81 of the days i've done a workout
in the last 150 days right so i'm going
to the gym about six times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivatio live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
one of the things you said there um as
you as you finished that piece was was
for me
the point about why instead of how was
also a really good piece of sales advice
right and you wrote a book about sales
to sellers human 2012 you wrote that
book um
when you write a book i know because
i've written one myself not written as
many best-selling ones as you have or as
many as you have but
even the journey of writing the book
changed me because you do so much
research that you you absolutely it
almost seems like it does more for you
than it does the reader but um what did
you learn about sales that you took away
and that stayed with you for the rest of
your life from writing that book i mean
so much on both like the the big picture
and on the and on the tactical level so
so one thing is that
you know the the thesis of that book is
the sort of the animating ideas of that
book are that like it or not we're all
in sales so to some extent
i'm selling right now i'm not
necessarily selling a book i'm selling
saying hey i have something interesting
i'm making these claims and i think
they're more right than wrong and you
should believe them all right so no
money changes hands but that's a form of
sales all of us are doing that when
we're leading people we're selling when
we're dealing with our kids we're
selling all you know but the thing is
which most people haven't realized is
that sales has changed more in the last
10 years than the previous 1000 because
everything we knew about sales sales
sales
has come from a world of information
asymmetry where the seller always had
more information than the buyer in all
commercial transactions since the
beginning of civilization
the seller had more information than the
buyer this is why we have the principle
of buyer beware buyer beware is entirely
the result of information asymmetries
where the seller has more information
than the buyer the buyer doesn't have
any choices and the buyer doesn't have a
way to talk back that's how commercial
transactions were
since there were commercial transactions
and then boop ten years ago it all
flipped because now we have something
closer to information parity and most
people haven't wrapped their minds
around what a significant change that is
and to me it's not a difference in
degree it's a difference in kind and so
to sell today where we're in this
landscape where we're selling all the
time
and we're doing it in this remade
landscape calls for an entirely new
approach and what's caused that that
shift is it because of the internet yeah
totally and you can find out anything
about what you want to buy reviews that
you know absolutely absolutely if you
look at say even buying a car in the
united states in the last 15 years um
you know
literally 15 years ago you go into a car
dealer that car dealer knows more about
toyotas more about camrys more about
cars than you ever will all right buyer
beware now literally the last car we
bought i mean my wife walked into the
car dealership with the factory invoice
price of the car hello i know how much
you paid to
to purchase this car for yourself and i
know what the going margin is for
dealers in this area therefore
but that's true in everything it's true
in b2b it's true in in hiring
um you know i i early in my life i took
a couple of jobs that were really stupid
to take and if had there been something
like linkedin or glassdoor
i would have known in advance what a
hell hole that those places were you
know and so you know and so so this
world of from information asymmetry to
information parity is is huge and and it
calls for a different set of skills um
the skills of
again simplicity
if you look at the research right and
you pound on it
for a year
trying to make sense of this research
you find that there's three key
principles and they start with a b and c
that was basically
that was luck um attunement which is can
you get out of your own head into
someone else's head hugely important
buoyancy um you know from from being an
entrepreneur that when you're selling
anything you're getting rejected all the
time one seller told me that he says i
live in a sea i live in an ocean of
rejection so buoyancy is how do you stay
afloat in a notion of rejection and then
clarity is how do you go from
solving existing problems
to identifying hidden problems because
here's the thing
problem solving as a skill
totally overrated
because if your customer or prospect
knows exactly what its problem is
they don't need you very much they can
figure it out themselves where do they
need you more when they don't know what
their problem is or they're wrong about
their problem so this premium has
shifted from problem solving to problem
finding can you surface problems can you
identify hidden problems um
and then also just think about
information it used to be that the very
nature of expertise was that expertise
meant you had access to information
nobody else had
now everybody has the information
so instead of being a good information
access you have to be a good information
curator a very different set of skills
can you see the big picture can you
synthesize can you simplify can you find
the hidden patterns um you can you know
detect what's really going on beneath
the welter of information and so these
are the skills that matter most in
any kind of persuasive job which is
all jobs
interesting it's it's i was thinking
about the importance of being being a
bit of a chameleon
when you're talking about empathy and
being able to find out what the unknown
unknowns about their challenges and
stuff like that
there is okay so let's let's go to a
tournament here for a second so a two
minute is perspective taking um can you
can you get out of your own head and see
things from someone else's point of view
and there are some really really good
science behind that what it shows is
that actually being a chameleon
is helpful and in this in this regard
you've all we've heard okay so let's
let's let's talk about this is like the
first cousin of manifestation okay okay
so it sounds like bs but this one isn't
it's mimicry
mimicry so let's say okay i'm gonna i'm
coming in to make a sales call on steven
i'm gonna sell you my you know
you know lifetime subscription to
rutabagas or something like that all
right and i'm looking to see how you're
sitting and i'm saying okay you're
sitting like this
yeah and then and then okay here are his
hands classed like that and then like
you're smiling and then maybe you lean
back in your chair and i mirror okay and
you're told to do that it seems like
complete bunk
uh-uh there is a pile of research
showing that the ability to chameleon
like that to reflect back people's words
and gestures is powerful
not as a way to
[Music]
deceive people
but as a way to understand where they're
coming from that is the way we
understand where people are coming from
is in some ways to inhabit them fully
by appropriating their gestures in
language and so this is one of those and
there's a really famous paper by adam
golinski at columbia university about
the advantages of chameleons in
negotiating being able to
shift your colors shift the way you do
things um in order but again not to
deceive
to understand um and so there's some
really powerful research in that one of
the best things you can do
is again i mean i see i keep coming back
to the theme that you sort of struck at
the beginning which is simplification is
a lot of times especially in technical
sales so we get in the weeds here a
little bit
the reason technical sales people go
awry
is they use their own
specialized
lingo
in their own specialized language
because they love it and it makes them
feel proud and they feel like it makes
them experts and the customers and
prospects have no idea what they're
talking about and the customers and
prospects use simpler less precise
language but you should use the
customer's language rather than your own
when you use even even something like i
hear i remember being in one
circumstance where somebody was talking
about trying to sell somebody something
i was talking about kpis key performance
indicators the person clearly did not
know what a kpi was they didn't know the
difference between kpi and kfc
and you know and and i'm like okay like
let me i think i need to intervene here
and say okay
keep performing kpi is key performance
indicator but had that guy not done that
he would have completely lost the person
he was trying to persuade because he
wasn't using
he wasn't using that person's language
he was using his own specialized lingo
super interesting i was thinking then as
well as you said that when you're
talking about mimicking about
a technique that's really proven to work
when i'm in conflict resolution with my
girlfriend which is if i repeat what she
just said back to me
it seems to defuse the situation
remarkably so she says because usually
when people have arguments it's kind of
you're not listening to them and you're
not being listened to so you're just
kind of shouting on repeat like a broken
record but one thing that i've learned
over the last i think six months that
when we do have a an issue and it's
clear that she doesn't feel heard if i
just say to her i'm gonna like i don't
know how i say i usually say um can i
just repeat back to you what you said so
i'm so i'm clear that i understand it
the broken record thing stops
but but part of it also is that it's
that's also that's not i think i think
sometimes we position these kinds of
things as
as tricks yeah but when you say what she
said you better understand what she
means yeah exactly it's not a trick it's
actually an act it's an act of
perspective taking and i'm not doing it
to trigger yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll say
i just want to be clear babe
this is basically how you feel you're
saying that
and the minute i do that she goes yeah
and that's it
and then she'll listen to my response
because i think she now feels understood
and i think there's kind of synergies
with what you're saying with me oh
there's no there's no there's no
question but that's basically this is
one of the areas where people go awry
they have a hard time getting out of
their own head
and seeing things from someone else's
point of view it's something we're not
innately great at it's something that
i'm not innately great at it's something
that i've really really worked on i
think it's central
in
any kind of persuasion and it's it's
obviously huge in any kind of in any
kind of writing because i'm dealing with
this vast army of people who i don't
even know i can't even see i can't you
know the the scary part is that if i am
not attuned and if i don't take people's
perspective in a book
i can't see them
shrink their face and look confused i've
lost them forever
you also talk a lot about pitching and
pitching is a huge part of yeah i mean
pitching is everything yeah you know to
get people to come on this podcast
sometimes we have to pitch and to get
you know someone to want to date you
you're doing a pitch to raise investment
i pitch so what have you learned about
the art of someone that's good at
pitching and a good pitch
okay this again you asked earlier what
this taught me this this line of
research taught me and one of the
biggest things it taught me was about
what i'm about to
drop on you which is that i had gotten
pitching completely wrong right there's
some really interesting research out of
stanford and out of uc davis where they
followed around
movie producers who were going to
studios to pitch and they were they
actually recorded these pitches a few
hundred of them i think and looked to
see which were successful and which were
not and the most important
criterion the most important thing was
was the following is was that the people
who were successful
looked at the people that they were
pitching
as partners all right and so instead of
so i used to think pitching was like
this kind of song and dance like i do a
little tap shoot
and they like take out their checkbook
no what you what you that's not the
response that i mean that's great if you
get that response you don't get that
response
the response you want is this hey that's
interesting have you thought about x y
or z that the goal of pitching is to
invite in the other side as a
collaborator
that's the key for any kind of pitch uh
at a at a macro level and that's totally
changed the way that i pitch i pitch in
a much more collaborative way in the
past when i was younger i you know had
this elaborate dog and pony show in my
head thinking that if i executed that
performance perfectly i would get a cent
and that didn't happen
i remember it just reminded me of a time
when i was running social training i
remember pitching to we just launched in
america and i was pitching to i think it
was uber for their global account
and um
one day late at night i was looking at
the email thread and i saw at the bottom
of the email thread that we called
ourselves people salespeople
and i remember thinking like is that
should we really be calling ourselves
sales p people all like should we be
calling ourselves because in the us i
think people call themselves like
partnership manager
because the the term sales it's kind of
like i don't know if it's giving the
game away but it sounds transactional
like i'm trying to give you you know
so what do you think about that should
we be changing our titles to like
something else
such an interesting question so i
intentionally because this is sort of
the way i like to do things i
intentionally put the word sell
in the title of that book because that's
what we're doing but i faced some
resistance because what i did some
survey research in the u.s showing that
when you ask people when you think of
the word sales or selling what's the
first word that comes to mind and people
had all these horrible words pushy
sleazy pressure easy pressure um
so it has a bad association so
but i i wanted to try to
win back the word probably didn't do it
that successfully but for years
i don't think people like being sold to
i mean i think one of the interesting
trends i see is is when they
is referring to those folks as customer
success they're we're in customer
success
i want someone to help me succeed yes
oh that's good news we use that in our
company in san francisco at the moment
we have a customer success manager and
that's in fact all of our terminology is
your job is to get customers from the
door to success
so that's good to know and we did
actually kill the the sales title yeah i
think that i i think customer success is
better than sales i think that account
executive is
sounds like
someone trying not to say sales yeah
and their job is to retain you
yeah yeah
and the other thing that really like
stood out to me and i i didn't delve
further into it because i wanted to
explain it was this this story about the
blind man with the sign
and the sign said i am blind and when it
changed from i am blind to it's
springtime and i am blind people donated
more to this homeless man yeah yeah
that's a story that's not a study yeah
okay so yeah yeah yeah but the idea is
is that the idea is is that we need we
need context and and in some levels we
need a why that is um that p that people
said
that the fact that he was the fact that
he was blind is significant and there
was some degree of empathy but when
people were reminded that it's
springtime
in new york city and he couldn't see
anything that changed the emotional
tenor of it and this is this is this is
the thing about about about stories that
we sometimes miss is that we sometimes
think about
oh should i go with the story i should
go with facts and the answer is yes
because
stories are facts in context delivered
with emotional impact so adding that
it's springtime
is a fact because it was springtime it's
a fact we added a fact but what you also
did is you enriched it with context and
delivered it with some emotional impact
and that's what made it persuasive i
literally think the reason why my
company was successful and my company
grew from like zero people to 700 in
about six years was because from and we
never had a sales team ever until the
point i resigned
like last year and i say this to
entrepreneurs when i meet them all the
time can you give me one piece of advice
i'm starting an agency business i'm
trying to win clients my one piece of
advice was from day one
i told stories
and the story that i told when we
started in 2014 was um we are the social
media illuminati we're the kids that
decide what all the kids talk about and
i would go around the world and the
country showing this presentation which
showed that we could make anything the
number one trending topic in 30 minutes
and it was all this story and
i never ever in my life felt like there
was one occasion where in that six years
i pitched to anybody i was just this
storyteller it was my full-time job go
around and tell stories that make people
feel uncomfortable to the point that
they think we've got a power that they
need so
when i when i meet entrepreneurs these
days my singular piece of advice is like
please never pitch if you get a chance
to speak on stage [ __ ] graphs right
don't try do everything don't no one
cares about your [ __ ] business but
find a story and it's funny in my last
three years at social chain every single
presentation i did no matter what this
stage was no matter if there was 15 000
people in obama was on stage or if it
was 20 people i opened up with the same
thing which is i walked out and went
and that's exactly why she stopped
talking to me she put the phone down and
told me she would never talk to me ever
again
that's the first two lines i say i don't
say hi my name is steve and i'm from
social chain and then people sit on the
edge of their chairs and they start with
this story about my mum which is
incomplete exactly till the end exactly
because so
and i i think that's so unappreciated
because
and i almost don't want to say it
because now i'm like my life's going to
get harder
because everyone's going to but it just
works so well for me and but this is
this is this is this is true for
everything i mean one of the things that
you want to do as a writer is you want
to keep people turning the page and what
the way a way to keep people turning the
page is to say what's going to happen
next so you you lead with those two
sentences i'm like okay
what's going on and what's going to
happen next yeah
that's all i want to know yeah exactly
now if you don't have something at the
end that makes the customer's life
better
all you have is a you know you're you're
a you're a wandering minstrel telling
stories you're not a business person but
if you have something that can land with
an impact that can transform that
person's life then you then you win
and then your other book before we get
on to your new book when
timing is a science not an art
i was i was really reading through all
of the the summary pages of that book um
and i was reading about chronotypes
which i thought was a really interesting
concept that there's because it kind of
challenges a lot of the conventional
thinking my understanding of chronotypes
please correct me if i'm wrong here is
that different people are
motivated and awake and alert and do
their best stuff at different times in
the day
is that accurate or is it slightly
different no that's exactly right i'm
motivated they're motivated in part the
motivation comes from the fact that
there are some people who naturally wake
up late and go to sleep late
naturally there are some people who it's
biological right there's some people who
naturally wake up early and go to sleep
early and then there are plenty of us in
the middle and what the distribution
tells us is that about 15 of us are very
strong morning people larks naturally
get up early and go to sleep early about
20 of us are very strong owls
we naturally wake up late and go to
sleep late and about two-thirds of us
are in the middle
and
the this our chronotype changes
over time somewhat so little kids very
very lucky wake up early start running
around like crazy people from the get-go
teenagers as you might remember
in general
have a big shift toward lateness we you
know parents think teenagers are being
lazy when they're sleeping in when in
fact they're actually their bodies are
changing teenagers have a
move to a late chronotype from about age
15 to age 25 or so and then over time
most of us go back to
general luckiness but about one in five
of us naturally wake up late and go to
sleep late and a lot of those people are
really disadvantaged in conventional
work situations i feel like you're
talking about me oh is that is that you
yes okay so okay so here's else here's
what else we know about about uh evening
chronotypes
they test higher on intelligence tests
oh now you're just no because they test
higher on creativity
they're also more likely to go to prison
yes okay yeah so all right so it's a
mixed bag yes all right
but but but the problem is is that
this is why a disproportionate number of
owls become self-employed because
conventional work structures don't work
very well for them facts my my best
friend said to me when i was 18 he said
you're either going to go to prison i'll
be a millionaire and i and i'm i'm
fundamentally unemployable i can't get
up well so the reason why i wanted to
talk about this was because i always
thought i was bullshitting myself i
thought i was just an unorganized mess
but i genuinely like to wake up late and
i like to go to bed
at 3am
okay or 2am if you know on a good day
but i like what time do you typically
wake up i go to the gym at midnight oh
my god i work out for an hour and a half
at midnight like pretty much every day
okay and i wake up maybe
9
30.
okay so what time do you typically go to
sleep maybe 2 a.m three yeah and you
wake up a wedding nine nine nine thirty
okay so because i have to
because you have to but if you were to
let us but what if you you might sleep
until ten oh yeah i'd go if if if it's
the weekend yeah oh just go eleven
yeah yeah so so this is you're clearly
you're clearly an owl and here's the
thing it's like 20 of us are that way
and one of the disadvantages is that a
lot of the kind of life-hacking advice
says you got to get up at 4 30 in the
morning and win the day you got to get
up at 4 30 in the morning and meditate
for an hour and then free journal for a
half an hour and then you know do
high-intensity interval training for a
half an hour and then read three
newspapers in six different languages so
that yoga meditation show up so when you
get to your desk at 6 30 you are you
know and
hey some people can do that i'm not one
of those most people can't do that i
don't you know for me you know i'm i'm
not um i'm not an owl at all but i'm not
a very strong lark i'm kind of in the i
have the i have the most common
chronotype there is which is that i'm
slightly larky i'm not a full-fledged
lark but i lean toward that earliness
and the key for me is
going with that
do you know the problem for me my
girlfriend wakes up at 6 a.m and she i
swear she's up at five but she she gets
out of bed at about 6 a.m and she's
super early she sleeps she goes to bed
at 10 p.m
and i was like what am i going to do
with this this is there there are
differences between
you know average differences between
between men and women women in general
are
larkier than
men what's interesting is that um
as men age they become larkier so maybe
as you get older
they'll have more confidence together
is there a like a prehistoric or a uh
like an ancestral reason why we have
these different chronotypes and sleeping
patterns i mean i think we can make an
argument for it i think we can make an
argument for
uh an evolutionary reason for some of
these things which is that um certainly
there's an evolutionary argument for why
people between 15 and 25 roughly have a
dramatic shift toward lateness and i
think it's because in what you know
imagine we're we're evolving on the
savannah all right and it's night time
there's not
there's not electricity there's no
illumination you need people to
guard what's going on and so the people
who were able to stay up late people who
were young and fit and able to stay up
late
were actually incredibly valuable so
they were respected they were nourished
and so forth and so theoretically those
genes then got passed along in the
population so that the rest of us 10 000
years later
teenagers and people in their 20s end up
having evening end up having even
chronotypes there's also just something
to be said for it's also it's also a
very very interesting form of cognitive
diversity that we sometimes overlook so
what you see is that
our performance changes significantly
within a day so all times of day are not
created equal we tend to think that's
the case but um
generally what happens is that we're
that that
two-thirds of us forget about the owls
for a second
do better on analytic work heads down
um focus kind of work we do better on
that kind of work early in the day
rather than later in the day owls do
better later in the day rather than
earlier in the day and so
um but at the same point you you some
i'll sometimes do better on some of the
creative tasks a tad earlier not always
and people like me who are right kind of
in the middle will often do better on
creative tasks a little later in the day
because our mood is up but our vigilance
is down so that gives us some kind of
mental looseness but that's one reason
that i write in the morning
interesting um and it's something that i
did something that i became even more
dedicated to once i did the research on
timing
that's so interesting i i definitely am
i feel more creative and i feel better
equipped to
better able to express myself
specifically with podcasts and stuff
like that if there's slightly later in
the day yeah so i i my conversations are
much much better if i have them after
lunch than they are if i do them in the
morning
it makes i mean makes perfect sense if
you're an hour and so the idea here is
what i don't like with owls is that
we no no what i don't like the way that
album treat it is that
we we try to we put the onus on the
people with these evening chronotypes to
adjust when it should be that
organizations are adjusting to them
because you're loot you're losing
one-fifth of the talent pool
so interesting
and i always find myself actually doing
my work in the evening so during the day
i don't even endeavor to do my work i do
it when everyone else has gone in it's
about six seven eight nine at night
class after the gym yeah classic owl
behavior ugh i need to get an owl
necklace um
so you wrote this book the power of
regret yes and
i mean you know that the title
in and of itself
is challenging because people don't
perceive regret to be a thing that one
should
seek power from or that i mean it's not
a positive thing to have regrets in life
according to culture i guess my first
question is why of all the things that
you could write about and you told me
you've got some google file of all these
book ideas you have why did you have to
write a book about regret
because
um
i was dealing with some regrets of my
own
i'm at a point in my life where i
suddenly looked up and i have mileage on
me which is kind of shocking but i also
have some mileage ahead of me and i want
to be able to use it well and when i
look backward i've realized that i had
some regrets and what i found is that
despite what exactly what you're talking
about this idea that we have in culture
that oh never talk about regrets regrets
are bad they make you weak no regrets no
regrets forward thinking positive um
that when i talk to people about my
regrets
they leaned in
they were interested and they wanted to
share theirs and so i'm so glad you
pointed that out because
i didn't go with a more
elliptical side door title i wanted to
put that word regret
in big blue letters on the cover
to challenge people and try to reclaim
this word because
regret is
our most transformative emotion if we
treat it right
in the book you talk about various types
of regrets what were the types of regret
that inspired you to write this book you
said you had your regrets there yeah
well i mean i had so the well it was
really reckoning with these regrets so
i'll give you one regret that i had um
uh which is i mean i had plenty of them
which was um
regrets about kindness uh when i was
when i was younger when i was uh in in
in primary school and secondary school
and in um
um
university
and even beyond um
a lot of the regrets that i collect and
i collected a huge number of regrets i
had a lot of regrets about bullying
people regretting bullying other people
i was never a bully um
but there were many many times
when i was younger where i saw people
being excluded not being treated right
being left out
and i knew
i saw it and i knew it was wrong
and i didn't do anything and that bugs
me to this day it bugs me to this day
really
hell yeah
yeah i mean i have yeah it still bothers
me even talking to you about right now
kind of my cortisol level has spiked a
little bit
and the here's the thing about regret so
i could say i could take that and say no
regrets no regrets never look backward
always look forward okay that's a really
bad idea or i could say oh my god i am
the worst person in the world i am just
horrible and that's debilitating that's
an even worse idea what i want to do is
actually listen to those regrets because
regret does two things for us
it clarifies
and it instructs so the fact that those
regrets stuck with me for 10 years 20
years 30 years that's telling me
something
it's telling me what i value it's
telling me i actually value kindness
that something that's important to me
and as i think about that i think well
who do the people who are the people i
admire a lot of the people i admire are
kind people people who treat others well
so it's clarifying and it's also
instructing me
what to do next now this is mundane but
it here's the thing if i'm ever at a
if i'm ever at a social gathering or any
kind of gathering and i see you know
sometimes there are people like clump
together talking and every once in a
while you see people sort of left out on
their an island of their own i always
reach out pull that person in and that
is a consequence of being
embarrassed and regretful about letting
people be left out earlier in my life so
regrets clarify what val what matters to
us and they instruct us on how to do
better
why use a couple of examples in the book
like you know angela angela jolie her
quotes and stuff like that why
don't why are we living in a culture
where we
don't ever want to admit we have regrets
what is it about humans where the idea
of having a regret is such a negative
thing
it's it's it's several things i mean
part of it is is that
regrets aren't fun they're aversive
right they don't feel good all right
they clarify and instruct and we might
want the clarification and the
instruction but you got to have a little
bit of the pain to begin with so
that's one thing second thing is that
no one ever teaches us how to deal with
negative emotions that's the big problem
i think is that and so what happens is
when people especially younger people
feel a negative emotion they think oh my
gosh there's something wrong there's
something wrong with me i'm broken
what's what's uh this camp this
everybody else is so pi everybody else
is so positive i must there must be
something wrong with me when in fact
they're just
human beings and the other the third
thing i think is that
you alluded to this earlier is that it's
a very
we have become a very performative
culture we have a culture where we're
performing
all the time rather than being authentic
and we like to perform courage
so when we say no regrets
that is
play acting courage
real courage is staring your regrets in
the eye and doing something about them
interesting
and there's something there's something
about i guess
this is like a wider point i wanted to
ask you about the book um which was
people don't seem to like and i talk
about this a lot in this podcast because
it's something that i know
one reason i talk about is because i
know it's kind of slightly triggering
but i also think it's kind of true which
is people really don't like taking
responsibility
for their outcomes in life interesting
point and now this sometimes this gets a
little bit political or whatever i'm
really not a political person um but
i've noticed this trend of people not
liking responsibility that not liking to
be attached to their outcomes unless
they're good outcomes right so if it's
success we achieve something great that
was me if something goes wrong that is
uh the political party in charge that is
someone else's fault etc etc and i i as
i was reading through this new book of
yours
that theme kind of
it felt like much of the reason people
don't like to own their regrets is
because then they have to own the
responsibility and we're like shitty at
that
it's a good point because here's the
thing regret requires
agency okay it's a difference between
regret and disappointment disappointment
is hey things didn't happen and it
wasn't my fault regret is your fault and
you have to face that now here's the
thing but when you do that this is the
thing that bugs me is that when you do
that when you face it first of all it's
a lot easier than people think second
it's a lot more beneficial than people
think let's go back to some research
again there's there's
70 years of research on this question
about regret what it shows us is this
i'll give you a small example
let's say you're negotiating
you're negotiating and you're in
negotiation and let's say you make a
first offer and
it's not a great first offer okay
if you
then
think about that negotiation and
consciously think about what you regret
in that that negotiation you invite the
negative feeling remember regret doesn't
feel good you invite it
you do better in the next negotiation
you see this in problem solving
i'm trying to solve a problem ah i
didn't do it that right let me actually
think about what i regret in that
problem-solving exercise invite the
negative feeling
you do better in the next one strategy
same thing over and over again what you
see is that when we deal with regret
properly when we think about it
when we think about regret as a message
as a signal
it is a powerful force in doing better
in making better decisions and being
better problem solvers and finding
greater meaning in our life it is a
powerful it's an elixir if we deal with
it right the problem is
we don't know how to deal with it right
so some of us ignore our regrets we put
our fingers in our ears all right then
others of us
when we can't do that any longer become
debilitated by it we wallow in it those
are bad ideas both what we want to do is
we want to think about our regrets we
want to confront them and do something
about them and there's a systematic way
to do that and if we learn how to do
that teach people how to do that
they're going to be way better off that
i was thinking about a particular friend
of mine when you're saying that
specifically on the point of regrets
debilitating somebody and i was thinking
about this one friend i have and i know
the prospect of them really ever taking
responsibility or admitting their
regrets if i feel like they're they're a
little bit too fragile in the i don't
know the self-esteem whatever it might
be to invite negativity you call it like
inviting the negative feelings so what
they do is like a self-defense mechanism
is constantly um obfuscate their sort of
responsibilities in any situation and
the prospect of like thinking about
things they regret i know they would put
their fingers in their own run off so
tell me what is the systematic sort of
process for me having a conversation
with that person to get them to not be
crippled by the prospect of inviting
negative feelings because i think they
would fall into the trap of wallowing in
their own uh
deficiencies
as opposed to being motivated by it
yep uh because they haven't been they
haven't been taught how to do it well
right okay so so so let's think about
three broad steps
think of it as inward outward forward
inward out forward so inward and this
goes to exactly what you're talking
about
how do we think about ourselves and our
regret so a lot of people like the
people you're talking about just want to
boost their self-esteem
all right
the evidence again on self-esteem it's
pretty good self-esteem is totally
overrated especially when it's unhinged
from any real accomplishment now
self-criticism i love self-criticism
there's just not a lot of evidence that
it's very effective right the middle way
is something known as self-compassion
self-compassion it's a term pioneered by
kristen neff who's a psychologist at the
university of texas in the u.s
it sounds a little gooey
self-compassion but here's what it says
treat yourself with kindness
rather than contempt the reason your
your friends want to boost your
self-esteem is if they actually heard
their self-talk it would be lacerating
and vicious the way we talk to ourselves
is so brutal and so cruel we would never
talk to anybody out anybody that way
right and so here's the thing it's like
that old joke where a guy goes to a
doctor's office and he says doctor it
hurts when i do this and the doctor says
don't do that all right
don't do that treat yourself with
kindness rather than contempt treat
yourself with the same kindness you
treat somebody else recognize that your
mistakes and missteps are part of the
human condition all right think about my
regrets about kindness i've collected
regrets from thousands of people around
the world believe me i'm not that
special there are plenty of people with
regrets about kindness and also
recognize that any single mistake or
misstep is a moment in your life it
doesn't fully define your life so that's
the reframing inward now what else you
can do and here's the thing we're
totally wrong on this
talk about it disclose it disclosing
isn't unburdening i'll give you i mean i
as you know from reading the book i put
up a website called the world regrets
survey
with two tweets i got 15 000 regrets
from people in a hundred countries it's
crazy why because they want to talk
about it re disclosing isn't unburdening
the other thing again let's go back to
negative emotions and how we deal with
them emotions are blobby they're
amorphous they're abstract that's why
positive emotions feel so good and
negative emotions feel so bad so with
negative abortions writing about your
regret or talking about your regret
converts that blobby abstraction
into concrete words which are much less
menacing so
that's that's the second so so express
hour and then finally you gotta draw a
lesson from it okay and and here's the
thing about us human beings
we stink at solving our own problems
we're terrible because we're too close
we're too unmeshed in the details so
what you should do is actually get do
some techniques known as self-distancing
and so for that you can do things like
it's got sounds goofy
talk to yourself in the third person
you're deciding what to do how to
respond to a regret don't say what
should i do say what should steven do
some good evidence of that other kinds
of things and talk to yourself out loud
either way either way any kind of
self-talk like talking to yourself in
the third person is actually
advantageous there are other things you
can do you can imagine having a
conversation with yourself 10 years from
now because i have a pretty good sense
from analyzing all these regrets what
i'm going to
be concerned about 10 years from now and
it's not going to be whether i bought a
blue car or a great car
it's not going to be whether i had
pizza tonight for dinner or hamburger
it's going to be other things and then
another way to draw a lesson is the
single best decision making tool that i
know which is that you're faced with the
decision about what to do
ask yourself
what would i tell my best friend to do
when people you give people people come
to me saying oh dan i don't know what to
do
well what would you tell your best
friend to do oh that's easy i
you got the answer right there so
express inward treat yourself with
kindness rather than contempt
express outward make sense of it through
disclosure and language and extract a
lesson from it by getting some remove
and it's very simple it's very it can be
very habitual and it is a way to
transform these negative emotions into
positive forces
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewellery brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery the really wonderful thing
about crafted jewelry is it's super
affordable it looks amazing the pieces
hold tremendous meaning and they are
really well made i think i've worn this
piece for almost a year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed color
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly 50 quid people will
be surprised when they hear that they'll
probably assume that all of my jewellery
is like solid gold and cost thousands
and thousands of pounds but what's the
point when you can achieve the exact
same effect from a piece of jewelry
that's high quality and costs 50 quid
that's why i buy crafted counterfactual
thinking yes really interesting topic
that i was uh delving into your book and
nothing chapter three
and this idea that people have more if
onlys than they do
at least right in their life and the
example that you gave and i i'm thinking
about the graph on in chapter three in
my head is about bronze medalists and
silver medalists i find that really
compelling can you talk a little bit
about counterfactual thinking and how we
can live um better more motivated lives
by kind of yeah well it's something that
it's counterfactual thinking is
something that human beings do sometimes
you know for all of our flaws
our brains are freaking amazing we can
do all kinds of things we can travel
back and forth in time we can imagine
things that never happen is our
storytelling capacities are a very part
of our essential part of our cognition
and counter factual thinking is just
imagining
what the word says events that run
counter to the existing facts and so
there's some interesting evidence from
the olympics if you show people
photographs of olympic medalists on the
metal stand without showing them the
metals they receive themselves what
you'll find is that gold medalists look
really happy not surprising they've just
won a gold medal
however
you know who else looks really happy
bronze medalists bronze medalists are
usually beaming silver medalists
they often don't look so happy even
though they finished second in the world
here's what and it's all about
counterfactual thinking the bronze
medalist is doing what's called a
downward counter factual imagining how
things could have been worse and so she
says well
at least i didn't finish in fourth place
like that shmo over there who's going
home without any medal at all the silver
medalist does what's called an upward
counter factual she imagines how things
could have been better ah
if only i had
um pedaled a little bit harder if only
i'd taken that turn a little bit faster
i would be a gold medalist here's the
thing
regret is an upward counter factual it
begins with it only if only blah blah
blah
at least make us feel better
but they don't make us do better
if onlys make us do better make us feel
worse
and they help us do better
they make us do better by making us feel
worse that's the thing it's this here's
this this is why we have a problem with
it in order to get the instruction you
need a little bit of discomfort you need
a little bit of pain and and and what's
interesting about us and this is the
thing
as you exactly as you say we are much
more likely to counter and if only than
at least we're much more likely to do
counter-factual thinking that makes us
feel worse than feel better why are we
masochists no
because we are programmed for survival
and regret is part of our cognitive
machinery by imagining how things could
have been better and even in dealing
with a little bit of that pain we
improve in the future that's how we
learn it's how we grow
but in the world of social media where
every time i open up instagram i engage
in upward counterfactual thinking
because everyone's life is better than
mine yeah
that's maybe a little bit too much
feedback for a stable mental health
it's like let's go back to the joke the
doctor says you go to the doctor doctor
it hurts when i do this and the doctor
says don't do that
you know so
i mean i mean um
here's the thing we know a lot about
this we know a lot about social
comparison
um in the research and social comparison
in general
makes people feel
worse
and so what you should be doing the best
way to improve
is to
compare yourself to your previous self
that's the best kind of counter factual
thinking that's the best kind of regret
so if i go let's go back to my kindness
regret i have a kindness regret not
because oh my god my friend bill was
kinder than me and he posted on
instagram his all of his acts of
kindness that's who cares
i regret about kindness because i wasn't
as kind as i could have been
but current me is kinder than old me and
that's progress and that
brings meaning to our lives
yeah it's really tough isn't it in this
day and age to have a
smaller context of comparison and i
guess as you say the most the healthiest
and the fairest um context of comparison
is actually just like am i better than
yesterday or the month before absolutely
but here's the thing if people started
sharing their regrets on instagram
i think it would be trans i think it
would transform the conversation well
again
i i've collected regrets now from 18 000
people in 109 countries just by putting
up a website people want to share their
regrets
and the thing is when people and here's
the other thing that we mistake
this is important for leaders too we
fear that when we share our
screw-ups our mistakes our
vulnerabilities our regrets people will
think less of us
there's 30 years of research telling us
in general not in every case but in
general they think more of us
okay let's play a game they admire our
courage they admire our authenticity yes
sir
you said um
it would be a much better world if
everybody shared their regrets so let's
share our regrets i'll go first we'll do
three each you've given one already so
you're getting to think of two okay um
my first regret would actually be
something and it's the first thing that
came to mind is something you kind of
you alluded to there which is
um moments where i didn't practice
enough enough empathy and i reacted
without empathy so especially being an
employer over the years
um of course there's days where you are
busy or you are trying to solve a bunch
of other problems and your empathy slips
in moments and i think those are the
things that i still have as lasting
regrets and you know it's funny when you
told me about the story about being
bullied someone being bullied and you
not you seeing them being excluded but
not necessarily speaking up about it and
i played devil's advocate to say really
really i would i thought of a kid i
thought of a kid and i've and it's funny
because i remember a couple of months
ago thinking about him in my office and
it's been 20 years and i still remember
that kid being
bullied for having like black nail
polish and being you know wearing all
black and having long hair and being a
little bit different to the rest of the
guys and i still think about i still
worry about where he ended up yeah and
about how i at the time because i was
trying to fit into
was definitely not stopping it yeah i'm
not saying i was leading the charge but
i was definitely not stopping it and
that's funny that that stayed with me
for 20 years that tells you something
what does it tell me it tells you what
you value
you know
think about all the things that happened
20 years ago that you have no
recollection of yeah okay but that stays
with the fact that it's this regret
stays with you for 20 years is a signal
it's a signal it's telling you you know
what i
value
kindness i value
embracing people who might be different
and it's also instructing you as a
leader as a friend as a human being to
say
i'm gonna do a better job next time
that's why it's valuable if you plugged
your ears
and said i don't care about that if you
didn't have if we're not having this
conversation you might not you might
understand less what you value and you
might be actually a less kind person in
the future that's how a regret is
transformative
and you don't seem too traumatized by
having this conversation i'm not no i'm
not prioritized by it yeah that's my
point it's like it's it's like we're
completely over indexed on how
threatening it is that the the specter
of it is we we find quite threatening
but once we disclose it
we're fine and and also people don't
think less of us
that's because because what just
happened here is
the power of the power of regret i
shared a regret with you you didn't
think less of me for that i don't think
all right and then and then what
happened is like it triggered you to
share another to share a similar regret
which he said wait a second i have a
regret like that maybe i'm not such an
oddball and and i don't think less of
you for for doing that i actually admire
your willingness to share it with your
legions of listeners that you have this
that this seemingly you know um this
person with this seeming ideal life this
titan of the universe this guy who's on
dragon's den is like has a regret about
something 20 years ago and being uncan
unkind i think that's actually powerful
you know and so this is this is why we
should be talking about our regrets
here we go
oh okay so um
another regret that i have you tried to
get out of that no i wasn't joking i'm
joking
um so um
um
so
i did something called a failure resume
uh oh yeah i read about it a few yeah a
few years ago where i listed my
professional failures and screw-ups and
there were plenty of them and my one and
what i realized is that a lot of my big
regrets and here's what it is it's like
i have committed to projects okay i'll
give you an idea so i have a regret
about a business that i try to
start with um
taking some of the ideas and drive and
turning it into like a training business
and it was a total flop complete
disaster
and
i realized the reason was is that
i don't want to run a training business
that's not what i want to do with my
life and yet i did it
i was i had the wrong motivation and i
yeah i had the wrong motivation and i
wasn't fully committed to it and as a
consequence
it flopped and so
that is a regret now i could say oh no
regrets no regrets every business you
know a lot of business fails but for me
the lesson is
don't take on projects
you're not fully committed to
period and you know there's an old adage
i think it's derek sivers the guy who
founded um cd babies that i try to
adhere to now which is that if it's not
a hell yes it's a no yeah and and that's
that's an important that's an important
lesson so i have this flop in my past
and and i regret it but what i really
regret is not the flop itself but
the decision-making screw-up that i had
underneath it
and that regret and the lesson you
garnered from it will be is going to be
a tremendously informative thing if
you're if you have the humility the
self-awareness exactly to confront it
write it down and hold out in fact
exactly right exactly exactly okay so i
think you owe me one okay so i was
thinking about thinking a little bit
about what my next one would be and i
think my next one is it's an ongoing
regret interestingly it's actually one
that i'm aware of and haven't corrected
which is my relationship with my family
like i'm well aware whether it's from
sitting here reading the studies
whatever else
or even brony wears thing where she
interviewed people on their death bed
and asked them their number one regret
before they died i'm well aware that one
of my big regrets in my life will be not
being closed to my family but i'm not
seeming to do a ton about it i'm like
inching over the if you know if you
looked at my
my the effort i invested in my family
it's definitely going in the right
direction but just way too slow okay and
my
my my parents my dad in particular is
not getting any younger he must be seven
years roughly about 70 years old now and
i know i'm going to regret it i know i'm
going to regret it my dad is gone i
regret it now but i don't seem to be
shifting my behavior um as much as i
should be because it's almost like i'm
waiting for the day when it's too late
it's a weird thing it's a really weird
thing so that's a big ongoing regret
that i anyone been listening to well
call your mom like
i'll call you dad but i just i seem to
struggle with it for a number of reasons
so yeah
okay so one of the so in all these
regrets that i collected around the
world there were four core regrets that
people had one of them was that regret
right there connection regret which is
the regret if only had reached out
and its regrets about relationships not
only about romantic relationships mostly
not about romantic relationships about
the full spectrum of regrets of
relationships in our lives
and i have so many stories
so many
around the world
where people
they want to reach out
it's going to feel kind of awkward and
the other side's not going to care so
they wait a little longer
now it's even more awkward and they're
not going to care
and too many times it's too late and the
door closes fully and that is a regret
that does not go away
that does not go away so be right back
well
here where's my phone
a few pieces of advice here all right
and again
as with all as always this advice is
rooted in the research so let's talk
about feelings of awkwardness we feel
like it's going to be awkward there is a
pile of evidence showing when we do
something like this
it's way less awkward than we think all
right second we think the other side's
not going to care we're wrong about that
the other side always cares and so um so
i'll give you i'll give you a trick
though all right here's what you do
if you're wavering and you shouldn't be
but if you're wavering
make a phone call
to the stephen of 20 of 10 years from
now
stephen2032
what does steven 2032 want you to do oh
[ __ ] yeah so no comment we're done yeah
when we're done i think we know what to
do
really interesting i think sometimes as
well ego can play a role in it maybe not
so much with family sometimes with
family yeah the ego is always seems to
be very concerned with victory and yeah
you know and that seems to get in the
way we we are completely over indexed on
our feelings of awkwardness and that's
also part of it because it's a little
awkward it's a little awkward yeah it is
a little awkward but here's the thing
get over that push past the awkwardness
again piles and piles of research on
this we see it with some work on giving
people compliments sometimes we don't
especially at work we don't give people
compliments because think oh they're
going to think it's creepy and they're
not going to care and it's going to be
awkward nope
people appreciate compliments we say
bosses say oh i don't know if i should
thank people because it seems gratuitous
and they're not going to care uh no they
like it you know um
we're completely over indexed on
awkwardness we think everybody is
watching us and rating us like you know
figure skating judges oh you know like
your dad you're gonna you're gonna call
your dad and your dad is gonna like oh
that was a six no your dad's just gonna
be psyched that you called you know and
so and so that's and so so that's what
it is i i gonna call my father within an
hour of this podcast finishing okay
that's my birth
but you owe me another i do you know
what i have a regret and this is
something i'm wrestling with right now
can i ask you a question yeah when you
tell me the regrets does it make you
feel uncomfortable
in any regard a little bit yeah because
your body language changes yeah yeah no
it makes me feel it makes me feel it
makes me feel a little bit uncomfortable
so it is mine yeah and that's okay
because but here's the thing initially
but it's a great observation i i would
think i'm not watching my own body
language but my guess is that once i
discourage it i'm cool yeah yeah it's
it's all yeah but it but here's the
thing it's a little bit aversive but the
thing is don't run from that just deal
with it because once you disclose it
it's it's fine so one regret that i have
is that um
i this is going to sound weird i mean it
won't sound weird to you because you've
done this is that
i regret
never
having
built
something with a team that is more than
a single
product you see what i mean something
that is
more enduring something that that is in
a book yeah well something that is that
is more of a an organism that lives on
that and that and that has a
greater
wider impact so whether i don't know
what that is whether it's a non-profit
or a business or anything like that but
i've always been
think i've always been sort of more
artisanal rather than even inching
towards something even more industrial
and
i regret
not taking on that challenge now here's
the thing i got time
and so i'm thinking about that now the
other hand the other thing to think
about is like is that something that
i really want to do
and it might not be but that sort of
bugs me
a little bit
it bugs me a little bit that is
you know
i i i'm i i'm proud of all the books
that i've written and i'm proud that i
created these things but
they're all just
one-offs that is you can stack them all
right here
every about 20 years of work
you can put between my two hands right
now it would be interesting part of me
thinks god i wish
for something bigger i wish it were
out there more in the world
it's really interesting it makes me ask
why like than a book books are seen as
something that live on beyond the author
right huge tremendous impact yeah but
maybe it's i don't know some people tend
to be intrigued by the thing that they
didn't do so entrepreneurs are thinking
i wish i wrote a book and maybe authors
are thinking maybe i wish
business you know what i mean it's like
they say basketball players want to be
rappers and rappers want to be
basketball players so
i don't know maybe but it's but it's
possible to be it's possible to be it's
possible to be both so that one that one
doesn't linger with me as much as the as
the others i haven't have another regret
about and this is
you know it's pathetic i just can't
believe i'm not fluent in another
language yeah yeah same yeah i mean just
pathetic and uh you know and i've and
i've like i've studied french i've
studied japanese i've studied
spanish
and i'm not fluent in another language
that's pathetic
now if i had now again even the way i'm
talking about it is not good because if
you if okay here you go i'm violating my
own rule here so i said pathetic right
if you had told me
um you can't speak another language i
would not have said that's pathetic
stephen but i say it's myself so what i
should do is treat myself with kindness
rather than contempt and look for ways
to move forward but the good part of all
of this is that you know for me i'm at a
point in my life where again i got
mileage behind me but i got some mileage
ahead of me so i can do something about
these regrets what i don't what worries
me are people who get further along
and the clock runs out
that's a terrible place to be i don't
want to be there
okay my last regret
my last regret is again an ongoing one
which i seem to kind of it doesn't it
doesn't burden me but it's definitely
something that i have on a daily basis
it's just my health decisions so
every day
every week i probably consume a little
bit too much sugar that i don't actually
want to need to consume it's not doing
anything for me it feels like a lack of
discipline so and also i think i'm
gluten free so every time i eat bread or
pass or anything like that i have to
suffer the consequences for about two
days and i do it over and over again
because i love bread and pasta
but i pay the price every single week
it's like this ongoing battle with like
who i want to be
and my what you know what my body wants
me to do and what i end up doing that
seems to be a rolling recurring regret
and the pandemic taught me that our
health is like our first foundation
which is funny because you described
this as a foundation right right um
and i realized during the pandemic that
there's this tectonic plate that sits
under everything i've built and achieved
in my dreams and my relationships which
is my health and if you take away that
tectonic plate in fact i have nothing so
i got really obsessed about not obsessed
but i got really focused on my health
and
i even went and did a health check for
the first time ever in my life for no
reason a full body
two thousand pound
health check because i really wanna what
did you learn
nothing i haven't
i'm a
perfect specimen of health
the doctor said stop eating so much salt
and i was like [ __ ] how do you know that
so but other than that it was all good
but yeah yeah yeah but i think the
solution there a solution there is is to
um don't depend on willpower depend on
your environment to change your choice
architecture so yeah you know if you
order food from the grocery store order
food
first of all order food after you've
eaten
and then make sure you order food
without added sugar yeah and you talked
about habits earlier on i understood
like what my habit cycle was so there
was a drawer over there full of sugar
and i videoed myself pouring it into the
bin great and i replaced it with like
healthier options so when i go through
the cycle now perfect i've interrupted
the cycle perfect the types of regrets
we have something you talk about a lot
in the book and you identify this
difference between genders as well which
i find really interesting but one of the
things as well you say which i think is
a really important point for people is
that people end up regretting the things
the opportunities they didn't take
versus the ones they did absolutely
that's a really guiding principle for
our lives right i think so i mean you
see this especially as people age there
aren't a huge number of demographic
differences in regret but one of the
biggest ones is that when we're younger
we tend to have about the same number of
action regrets and inaction regrets the
same number of regrets about what i did
and what i didn't do but as we age
inaction regrets take over and i think
there are a few reasons for that i think
i mean one of them is that if we have an
action regret
we can sometimes resolve it or undo it
if i hurt somebody i can apologize and
maybe that can extinguish it a little
bit
but what really nags at us over time is
what we didn't do regrets of inaction um
and i think that there's a le i think
there's a lesson in here which is that i
feel like human beings
we should have a slight bias for action
we have a slight bias for action that
that when in doubt
act um and one of the things that i've
learned not through this research but
just through living is that a lot of
times we try to
figure everything out and then act and
that's hard because we can't figure
everything out but that acting is a form
of figuring it out and so taking small
steps and having a bias for action i
think is is generally healthy life
advice and and consistent with avoiding
those big regrets when you're 70 or 80
saying oh if only i had traveled if only
i had started a business if only i had
reached out to people who are now gone
yeah i am i was reflecting then as
you're speaking about the advice that
i've shared on this podcast before about
barack obama him saying that
when he had the big decisions he faced
in his life like taking up bin laden or
whatever he would get to 51 percent and
then make the decision and be at peace
and i reflected on that from my business
perspective because over time i'd
learned that
the consequence of like procrastination
was
tended to be much worse than the
consequence of like trying failing and
then going back to the drawing board
right right it was because the time
wasted in procrastination sometimes you
waste two years thinking about doing
something right whereas you could have
ran the experiment in three months and
found out the answer to yes or no
and um
and so yeah i think in my companies like
over the years i tried to create this
but as you call it the bias of action
where we would set really diligent time
frames and then we'd also be at peace
with the consequences we wouldn't reward
the teams based on the outcome we'd
award them
reward them or incentivize them based on
doing the experiment exactly exactly
exactly and this is i think that's
actually really important because one
way that i think about the world is sort
of in in sort of through an economic
lens which is like what is overvalued
and what is undervalued okay so almost
like like assets right so if you to me
the
planning as an asset
overvalued acting as an asset
undervalued um certainty
as an asset
totally overvalued experimentation as an
asset undervalued
and that and then when we think about
that we just sort of okay let's let's
think i'm going to buy what's cheaper
and sell what's more expensive
experimentation is just the for me is
the everything uh you know not even i
mean we talk about that word
so much here you wouldn't believe but
the reason why i use you see here today
this podcast is number one in the apple
charts at least number two on spotify
because of rogan but number one is
literally because i think we as a team
um have a culture of experimentation
where we like look forward to it and
always as we we call say around here
trying to find the one percent marginal
gain somewhere right it's like try
when the music you walk in if we make it
house music try changing the temperature
and see the impact that has and that
that kind of thing this whole podcast
the setup of it you're looking at the
the lighting everything can we find a
one percent somewhere and those one
percent compounding over time in our
favor
will they have a significant impact in
it it always has in my life so it's my
religion now uh experimentation is a
good religion and and i wish in our
schools we taught people
better we did a better job of teaching
people just the overall scientific
method because that's how we should
approach especially in business that's
how we should approach our lives we
should say what do what does scientists
do we want to think like a scientist
what do the scientists do they have a
hypothesis they test the hypothesis they
run a randomized controlled trial let's
try a let's try b oh wow a is a lot more
effective great i know that now now
let's run another and that's not and
that's how we should be thinking about
it but we have this notion especially in
business that to be in business you have
to be this omniscient
creature who's all-knowing and is
infallible and that's really really
dangerous
and going back to your point about drive
the principles which are most conducive
with experimentation are that you got it
autonomy mastery that's a great great
point that i hadn't actually even made
that connection until just now that's a
great point that threaded through
experimentation is you got to have some
self-direction the whole point of
experimentation is to get better that's
mastery and you have to have a purpose
behind it great point and then this
difference between genders you described
so men tend to regret they care more and
women tend to regret more than men fa
have family regrets yeah yeah those were
not massive differences those those are
not massive differences but they were
they were present they were they were
they were present it's one of the
demographic one of the demographic
differences the other thing which i
didn't doesn't come up in in my own
research but that there's some existing
academic research one gender difference
is um to oversimplify but not by much is
that is on sexual regrets so men tend to
regret the people they didn't sleep with
and women tend to regret the people they
did sleep with really yeah makes perfect
sense
rings true you the failure resume thing
when i when i saw that in the i think it
was the seven points in the book about
things to try
um
it felt quite depressive the idea of
creating a resume of i mean on the
surface yeah if i said to a friend of
mine listen what you want to do is write
down all the things you failed at yeah
in a long list yeah it feels quite
depressive
because you don't stop there right you
put that in one column if you stop there
yeah you're totally right it'd be a
total downer but what you do is you put
those failures and screw ups and
mistakes in one column in the next
column you list the lesson you learned
from it and in the third column you list
what you're going to do next time but
without those next two columns yeah it's
an exercise in
self flagellation but but it's an
exercise in introspection and
improvement if you explicitly find a
lesson from it and then commit to taking
action
that that that benefits from that lesson
and as this book goes off into the world
now what is the impact or the shift in
perception that someone listening to
this podcast now or someone that picks
up the book in the bookstore and what is
that shift in perception you're you're
hoping as the author
to create or inspire
what i want to try to do is reclaim this
emotion of regret and show people that
it's not a badge of shame it's actually
a potent and powerful part of their life
if they if they
deal with it well that everybody has
regrets regrets make us human and if we
treat them right if we're grown-ups and
think about them they can make us better
and if we do that you end up with this
cascade where people
we normalize certain kinds of negative
emotions and we have have this cascade
where we're more open talking about it
and people get better and better and
better
it's a brilliant book and it's a
brilliant book because as someone that
doesn't love reading books to be honest
i like listening to stuff um as harry
said it's fluff free
so you know that every second or minute
invested in this book returns a minute
of value as opposed to you trying to hit
a publisher's word count which i see a
lot of the times because i end up
reading a lot of books when i do this
podcast so thank you for writing a very
important book one that's very
challenging because it does debunk a
conventional form of thinking that
regret is this awful thing that we have
to hide from and conceal and i think in
getting people to be more open about the
regrets as you've seen from our
conversation here you inspire and you
also liberate people from the [ __ ]
that is weighing them down or making
them feel inadequate in certain ways and
it creates a culture of transparency and
authenticity which as we all know is
good on all bases of life to be open in
yourself and to be living in line with
yourself so thank you for writing such a
brilliant book i hope everybody goes and
gets it because it's one of the books
that i'm really really glad i read
irrespective of the fact that you were
coming here so thank you we do have a
closing tradition on this podcast which
is the previous guest writes a question
for the next guest and i don't get to
see what it is until i open the book
okay they've got great great handwriting
okay interesting
if there was one singular idea that had
the most profound impact on your life
what would it be
brackets what's the first thing that
comes to mind
okay
the first thing that comes to mind
the first thing that comes to mind is a
concept
um
from
originally from i think john rawls who
was an american philosopher that is
known as the birth lottery
the birth lottery
and
here's what it is
that too often
we look at our situation in life
and we don't realize how much of it is
the circumstance
of our birth
and
that's true when things go south and
it's true when things go well so i'm a
case in point
i [ __ ] lucked out how did i luck out
because i was born in america after
world war ii
and my parents both had university
educations and i'm a white man and i'm
straight and
i won the [ __ ] lottery okay and
if i didn't do something with my life it
would be pathetic now here's the thing
suppose that i were born same me but i
was born in a village in guatemala in
1850
i might not have lived to be 30 years
old
how about if i go back even further in
time sorry
is okay so you can see by looking at me
i have glasses on i have terrible vision
all right i can't see like like like
like i asked my ophthalmologist what is
my vision in numerical terms and she
says you're legally blind okay so
imagine if i were born 400 years ago
there's i'd be a dead man all right and
so a lot of times our circumstances are
the product of this birth lottery and
when we realize that we actually can use
our privilege as a force for good but we
can also have empathy for people who
didn't who didn't win the birth lottery
and actually
try to create a world in which everybody
has a fair chance
it weirdly unfortunately can also create
a bit of entitlements in some people
absolutely if they don't realize it
that's my point yeah absolutely it's
like so so you know so you look at some
people it's like oh i work for
everything i have and that's true you
did work but the thing is
you won the bird lottery
you also won the birth lottery you had a
you had a huge advantage you know and
and you look at you look at people who
are
you look at people in this country or
any in in in the united states who are
immigrants particularly if they were
forced out of their
uh out of their home country and how to
remake a life in a place where they
didn't speak a language that you know i
didn't have to do i didn't have to do
that and um and you look at people one
of the things that i've discovered over
time is
you know
even things like what you look at it
look like as a form of a birth lottery
like in america as like a a tall
straight white man i walk into a room
nobody immediately says oh he doesn't
know what he's talking about oh he's
here because of special privilege right
if i were a if i were a woman if i were
a person of color if i were disabled if
i were gay they would say wait a second
i don't know and so and so now that now
does that mean that again it's sort of
like i mean i haven't thought about this
it's sort of like dealing with regret
okay so i could ignore that saying oh no
no birth lottery that's nonsense blah
blah blah blah blah or i can say oh my
god
i deserve to be punished
because of this or i can say let's think
about it what do i do i have an
obligation to use my privilege as a
force for good and i have an obligation
to make the world fair
and that's what i do with it amazing
thank you so much daniel for your
honesty it's uh tremendously inspiring
and uh thank you for your time today
you're someone i've followed for a long
time so it's a real honor to sit here
with you i have so enjoyed this
conversation i really have thanks for
having me amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you